et donc on débute cette page cinéma avec
vous Tony chasslas bonsoir vous êtes de
la verrière et vous avez sorti votre
cinquième court-métrage jamais sans mon
tél alors rapidement c'est l'histoire
d'un jeune qui doit passer trois jours
sans son téléphone portable son
téléphone portable tout court pour en
fait valider le mystérieux testament de
sa grand-mère alors pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez décidé d'écrire de tourner ce
court-métrage parce que c'est ce qui
m'est arrivé en fait je me suis retrouvé
sans téléphone portable pendant
plusieurs jours et l'aventure a été
folle en fait parce que j'étais plus du
tout habitué à me retrouver sans
téléphone portable je me suis dit que ça
pourrait être amusant de partager
l'expérience c'est d'en faire une
histoire donc j'ai décidé d'écrire le
film comme ça oui parce que finalement
son téléphone portable on s'en sert pour
tout aujourd'hui
c'est un défi que vous pourriez relever
autour du plateau passer trois jours
sans son téléphone ce sera compliqué
c'est je pense que ça serait très très
difficile mais c'est vrai que pour nous
en fait c'est un outil de travail au
quotidien de notre téléphone portable
donc même pour vous Charline Garcia je
suppose alors nous on fait le combat
avec les jeunes de lâcher d'accord nous
on aimerait bien qu'il fasse trois jours
sans au plus grand bonheur des parents
aussi mais je trouve d'ailleurs que la
difficulté c'est aussi que ça remplace
des objets du quotidien parce que
maintenant on achète plus forcément de
réveil notre téléphone c'est notre
réveil enfin c'est ah oui c'est la
lumière je suis pas encore à ce niveau
là mais bientôt moi je paye avec mon
téléphone aussi ah oui c'est vrai aussi
oui bah oui tout ce qui est en ligne on
peut payer avec mon téléphone il y a nos
mails le GPS la musique il y a tout quoi
un jour peut-être deux jours déjà c'est
difficile trois jours ça devient ça
devient long
donc on va parler de votre court-métrage
dans un instant mais juste avant je
voudrais qu'on regarde le teaser
justement sur jamais sans mon tél
[Musique]
je serai chez vous jeudi soir
alors dans ce teaser on voit deux
acteurs Willy et Régis
Ivanov quels sont les autres acteurs que
vous avez choisi qui qui joue dans ce
court-métrage alors il y a Maurice et de
Gourdon qui joue la grand-mère qu'on a
pu voir dans comment s'appelle la série
déjà
appelé mon agent en français 10% voilà
pardon
Marie-Louise Compain qu'on voit là
récemment la vue dans Netflix dans la
série en place et il y a deux trois
autres rôles mais c'est vraiment des
petits rôles c'est des rôles secondaires
vraiment et donc vous avez tourné dans
les Yvelines on peut apercevoir quelques
images dans quel lieu est-ce que vous
avez tourné j'ai tourné à la verrière
principalement les extérieurs à la gare
de la verrière
il y a la mairie aussi j'ai tourné dans
la mairie de La Verrière grâce à Nicolas
Dainville le maire qui m'a prêté la
mairie pendant toute une journée donc on
a tourné également Élancourt dans le
cinéma ou le film va être projeté
à Coignières et mort pas donc c'est pas
la première fois que vous tournez un
court-métrage dans les Yvelines vous
êtes attaché au territoire
en fait c'est un lieu où j'ai adoré
grandir j'y vis encore je pense que je
partirai pas en tout cas pas tout de
suite c'est pas prévu et non je trouve
que c'est une belle ville j'ai appris
plein de choses là-bas on a une
mentalité assez particulière souvent
quand je rencontre des gens de Paris ou
autre
ils se rend compte que dans les Yvelines
en tout cas et dans la verrière le
Menier l'élancourt on a vraiment une
mentalité particulière en fait donc moi
je veux représenter ça et je trouvais
important de tourner de là où je viens
en fait pas tourner dans des endroits
qui me correspondent pas forcément des
endroits que je connais
et donc vous avez reçu trois fois le
prix du meilleur court-métrage
indépendant au film au Festival du film
de Paris New York et Milan c'est un plus
pour votre carrière je suppose
la reconnaissance parce que c'est pas
des festivals avec du copinage c'est des
personnes qui me connaissent pas donc
ils suivent vraiment mon travail en fait
c'est vrai c'est pas parce que je suis
un tel qui est dans telle société de
production que je gagne le prix c'est
vraiment parce que mon projet l'aura et
alors vous travaillez sur ce
ce souvent des projets qui qui sont
blonds
je crois que j'ai commencé en janvier
l'année dernière
d'accordage on a tourné en mai en mai de
l'année dernière avril mai de l'année
dernière et donc pour pouvoir réaliser
un court-métrage de 30 minutes il faut
une équipe de combien de personnes
autour on était entre 10 et 15 en
général entre 10 et 15 personnes sur sur
le film on a tourné une fois c'est
toujours et une autre fois on a dû
tourner trois jours je crois et vous
avez d'autres projets à venir ou pas là
j'ai une série qui
s'appelle goodgame que j'ai tourné en
2019 ou 2020 avec le covid je sais plus
trop
en fait j'ai gagné pas mal de prix pour
cette série j'ai gagné 15 prix et du
coup je dois faire la première saison
cette année en fait aussi un
crowdfunding pour récupérer quelques
financements et pouvoir tourner la
première saison
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
si vous souhaitez regarder jamais sans
mon tél rendez-vous samedi à 16h30 au
ciné 7 de élanc